first up he is a 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate and author of the
war on normal people the truth about
America's disappearing jobs and why
universal basic income is our future
that's all the time we have played
[Applause]
I haven't read your book but I read the
title I think I get it all now
no okay so I'm gonna ask you the same
question if as many the contenders
who've been on our show 23 of them I'm
gonna run to be 23andme 23 people are
running why you I'm running for
president because I'm focused on solving
the problem that got Donald Trump
elected in the first place in 2016 he is
our president because we automated away
4 million manufacturing jobs in Michigan
Ohio Pennsylvania Wisconsin
all the swing states that we needed to
win and my friends and Technology know
we're about to do the same thing to
millions of retail jobs call center jobs
fast food jobs truck driving jobs and on
and on we have to wake America up to the
fact that it is not immigrants that are
causing these problems it's not
immigrants am i right to get them to
applause and so we need to solve these
problems for the American people and
that's how we beat Trump in 2020 that's
how we move the country for yes yeah you
got your lane you got an issue that I
think nobody else has which is they're
coming for your jobs and what jobs are
we talking about I know you talk about
in your book jobs that involve a routine
right something that is repetitive those
are the jobs that can be replaced by
machines and Automotion
information and artificial intelligence
yes what areas are we talking about 44%
of American jobs fall into either
repetitive manual work or repetitive
cognitive work so we're talking about
retail jobs call center jobs fast food
jobs retail well retail 30% of American
malls are closing in the next four years
because Amazon's sucking up twenty
billion dollars in commerce every year
oh and you don't think of that as an
automation thing because the ROI it's
not going in and doing this I still
think of retailers go to the mall and
how could a machine if I asked do I look
cute in this you know
does this make me look fat no but your
yeah people don't care about that
anymore they buy everything online yeah
yeah and if you go to the Amazon
Fulfillment Center it's wall-to-wall
robots so that's why retail is also
being automated away okay so that's part
of your plan and then the thing that's
in your book ubi which is a bowel
disease I didn't name it I know but
every time I hear ubi I think it's one
reason why we rebranded it the freedom
dividend and it's a plan where
everything gets $1,000 a month everybody
gets it to everybody
rich poor yes you too I got my eye on
these Tom Ford cufflinks because I saw
they were 12 grand it was too rich for
my blood but if I get that bonus I'm
gonna go now okay so everybody got under
stand how much would that cost in total
for a year in this country well the
headline cost gets a lot lower than
people think because a lot of this money
is just going to go back right into the
economy it's the trickle up economy
right it's gonna poor people spend it
yes if I gave you a thousand bucks a
month you might not even notice but if
you put $1,000 a month in the average
American consumers hands it's gonna get
spent right in there Main Street
businesses it's gonna create two million
new jobs because that money is just
gonna go to tutoring and car repairs the
occasional night out it's gonna
circulate but how much right off the bat
is that we have to spend and do this so
the headline cost is around one and a
half trillion that's a year a year Wow
yeah that's real money but we just gave
away a trillion in a tax cut to people
who will never see it yes and defense
you could take it trillion out they
wouldn't they wouldn't notice it either
well the way we get the money is if you
look around how much did amazon pay in
federal taxes like on zero so think
about a trillion dollar tech comment
that's right
so hand over this so we have to create a
mechanism where the American public
actually benefits from artificial
intelligence and all these new
automations right so if we had even a
mild value-added tax and gave the
American public a tiny slice of every
Amazon sale every Google search every
Facebook ad every robot truck mile it
would generate over 800 billion in new
revenue which would be enough to pay for
the vast majority of this dividend of a
thousand dollars okay but to me this is
only part of the problem you're saying
people are gonna be thrown out of work
yep although a tsunami of unemployment I
think you're right because of automation
robots and so forth so now we're making
sure they don't starve we give the money
but what do they do all day it's not
just money people have to have a purpose
in life you have to have a reason to get
up in the morning no idea that was such
a controversial what people people need
a reason to get up yes bill finally
someone has said it yeah I'm Asian so
you know I like to work yeah
but but you and you did it on yourself
that's very politically correct
Americans need structure purposeful film
and all the things that jobs provide but
the biggest misconception about the
freedom dividend is that it's somehow
going to reduce work it's actually going
to create two million new jobs it's
going to recognize the kind of work that
we Jeff does yeah because of the
economic growth in the economy just
having more buying power okay so what
jobs are we getting there that were so
those jobs happily will keep some of the
Main Street stores open that would
otherwise closed but it would also start
to recognize the kind of work that my
wife does my wife's at home with our two
boys one of whom is autistic and right
now the market values her work at zero
it values all caregiving as at
essentially zero and so by having as
dividend in place not only do we create
new jobs we also start recognizing and
rewarding the work that's already going
on in our families and communities we
can actually expand what we think of as
work okay so one thing I like about when
I listen to you is that you are asking a
question I've asked many many times on
this show which is why in so much of
this country is Adi next to a
politician's name so toxic so toxic that
no matter who they're running against I
mean Roy Moore squeaked a victory out a
child molester watching he lost by why
is the D so toxic n and you talk about
this too I've been shocked Bill when I
go around the country how working-class
Americans feel like the Democratic Party
does not care about people like them is
not talking to them right and when I was
growing up the Democratic Party was the
party of the worship a little guy or gal
we need to get back to that I can't tell
you how much credit Donald Trump got
just for calling out the pain that many
of these communities are in and so if
the Democratic Party stops condescending
and says look we're here to actually
work on solving your problems we can go
very very far with many of the people
who voted for Donald Trump is this
because of identity politics well so I'm
the son of immigrants I understand the
impulse behind identity politics but
Democrats have to know that identity
politics is a very poor way to approach
winning national elections and it's a
very poor way to
in our country together we have to enact
solutions that will help all Americans
and when Martin Luther King championed a
guarantee and minimum income in the 60s
which is almost exactly like my freedom
dividend he didn't do it for any subset
of Americans he did it for all Americans
and that's again how we move the country
forward thank you good luck with your
campaign
you